I'm asked to do an independent
assessment
and and I read through the thing and I'm
pretty shocked
uh and uh and how how shoddy it is it's
just it's atrocious
and um shocking uh to me that this would
be submitted for anything I mean if I
submitted that I would expect to get
reprimanded if not uh basically tarred
and feathered by the FDA was that basic
was that because of the efficacy of what
you were seeing what was the most shock
it was just there was no real efficacy
data they weren't even testing the real
drug product they were substituting an
mRNA coding for a firefly protein
luciferase
um they so it was the mythology the
methodology of the whole thing basically
no it was it was completely inadequate
by any standards that I had been trained
on completely inadequate as a package
so as now they're rolling out warp speed
and you realize that this technology
that you were one of the experts on and
had the patents on all this stuff and
everything else as you realize that this
is going to be now pushed really on on
everyone in America with all this uh you
know the companies were going to have no
liability and all of this crazy stuff
what was your first red pill moment
related to that when did you realize
that something was wrong here well I
realized something was wrong when uh the
book that my wife
put together in February
very really in January and published in
the beginning of February uh called how
to prepare and protect yourself from the
novel coronavirus got censored in March
and taken down Amazon
uh so that that and and the
justification it took us forever to
finally get them to fess up as to why
because their usual policies they'll
tell you you know oh there's porn on
page 52 or whatever the thing is right
you fat-shaped somebody whatever your
sin is they'll usually tell you yeah
um they wouldn't tell us although in the
case of covet a little fat shaming
probably would help but okay
yeah but that's not allowed these days
uh so
any case uh finally uh the other shoe
drops
um we have violated Community standards
what are those Community standards
undefined but we we violated them okay
so that's the first time I ever heard
that phrase and and so it went uh
there was a series of things but in
terms of the Jab
uh
a couple of key things both of which
involved Canadians
uh really
um crystallize things for me
I got a
um
a call about
uh
from really out of desperation
from a Canadian physician practicing
Toronto who wants to be not named
uh his his office has been broken in his
computer has been Trashed by the
government I mean he's totally been
targeted for the sin of uh
prescribing Ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine and saving people's
lives
but uh he called me in
uh with brokered by Steve Kirch
and on a a Saturday evening
uh seems forever ago
and
was just appealing to me hoping that I
could get through to the Canadian
regulatory authorities
and help help them understand what was
really going on
he you know kind of naively and and um
and I had already managed I'd already
called in and had conversations and was
had ongoing conversations with senior
people at the FDA
but uh I don't know anybody in the
Canadian regulatory Authority and I
don't even know the Canadian regs that
well and so I had to say to him uh you
know we had this long conversation where
he was telling me about
how they were deleting any records that
he would enter having to do with Adverse
Events of his patients after they took
the Jab
and just totally disregarding what he
was observing clinically and furthermore
they were the government was enticing
children to take the jab with ice creams
and and for me this was an ethical
horror I'd never heard of anything like
this you know this is what I've been
trained to never do
uh you know on pain of losing my ability
to ever practice clinical research again
and uh
so I I had to tell him it's just we we
talked until midnight and I said there's
nothing I can do for you I just don't
know I don't know who to call I don't
know what to say
and I woke up in the morning and uh my
wife and I are both well trained in
bioethics
uh My Mentor in bioethics was her PhD
Mentor a guy named edel Shamu
and uh
and I woke up and I said Jill I know
what we can do for this poor guy
we can publish an article
on uh the bioethics of what's going on
with these vaccines
and the failure to enable informed
consent and the enticement and coercion
and what is the history of the bioethics
rules that apply Etc
and uh so that was that was the first
big one and I think that was the first
article out that really drilled into
what was going on wrong with the
bioethics
and so basically so basically you first
were concerned just about informed
consent this is before you had any sense
of what the vaccine injuries might be
right so this is just about so so at
that point I'm skating on thin ice
I'm hearing these injuries
uh and
um I know I'm seeing the amazings that's
going on
and uh
in gaslighting and you know information
control and everything blacklisting
that's going on
and so I'm trying to figure out okay how
can I navigate this this minefield
and uh say something that will move the
ball forward and get everybody to see
that this this isn't right what's going
on without just getting you know my head
cut off and labeled as a anti-vaxxer nut
case uh you know obviously I didn't
succeed very well in that
um uh but uh that was that was the
attempt was to thread the needle yeah
and I thought that bioethics was
something where I clearly had the cork
expertise and competence I was
absolutely on the right I mean there's
no ifs ands or buts about this topic uh
in in terms of what is right and proper
and so I thought well this is one thing
I can do here
that uh should be able to penetrate
through the mainstream media
and uh get people away so that's that's
what I focused on and that's focused on
uh for quite a few months was just
trying to uh be the voice of responsible
bioethics and drive that home
and and was any of that breaking through
to mainstream media I actually don't
recall seeing you yeah I was gonna say I
don't recall seeing you on CNN or on uh
Meet the Press or anything so basically
yeah so so you try that for a while and
then and then in parallel
uh u-pin and uh bioentec
were aggressively marketing to uh
characters for the Nobel Prize
Katie carico and Drew Weissman
and uh Katie is a former Hungarian spy
and Drew is a former Tony fauci postdoc
both of whom ended up working at UPenn
and there this is about a decade later
from after what I did my work
and they had this discovery that they
could use pseudo-uridine in the RNA and
get more immune response
and they were being marketed
aggressively because this is what you
know this is one way to play the game if
you want to get a Nobel Prize for your
Institution
uh as as the inventors of this whole
technology and concept and I was just
kind of pissed about being written out
of History
uh and so I objected to that then this
huge marketing campaign came at me about
um oh you you're absolutely not the
inventor
um you're lying you're misrepresenting
you know you're risk misrepreting your
CV and and uh and it's all about Katie
and Drew and uh you know New York Times
and CNN interviews for them and
everything and so I I just became a very
inconvenient uh uh squeaky wheel in that
whole environment and then when I'm
coming out with this messaging about
bioethics
I was already kind of uh uh got the
black spot
despite having worked with media for uh
almost two decades usually on background
the reason why you never heard of me
before is there I I have had multiple
hard lessons in the uh
the wisdom of the common DC saying uh if
they can't see you they can't shoot you
uh and and I I've you know as a
consultant I've been able to do what I
did by staying behind the scenes letting
my clients take the credit and uh just
kind of laying low and getting my
business done and collecting my fee
uh so that was a long-standing
intentional strategy Department of
Defense in particular but most clients
really don't like to have uh the
consultant
um uh be out front
uh so
right so you have the initial issue is
the coercion then the vaccines are out
you already had heard of some uh vaccine
injuries and things of that nature yeah
other Canadian comes in Byram
so Byram uh who I'd never heard of
before but he's an absolutely well
qualified vaccinologist immunologist uh
academic University of
uh gelf is that right I think
um
I may be confusing him with Matthias
Desmond uh so forgive me if I did uh so
Byram
apparently manages to grab
the common technical document for the
Pfizer uh
um submission uh for allowance to
proceed in humans
uh so common technical document we used
to call those inds it's the dossier of
everything they know about the product
uh and that they used to justify
initiating clinical trials
and uh and usually those are considered
confidential so the likes of you and I
can't get at them because otherwise we
would be able to go and try to reverse
engineer whatever the new product is
and so for whatever reason the Japanese
apparently put this you know Common
technical document is basically a
universal document that gets submitted
to all Regulatory Agencies all over the
world
and they put it on a server and Byram
had somehow grabbed it or one of his
buddies had and sent it to him and he'd
done an analysis of it uh most of it's
in Japanese but the figures and legends
are in English
and so we went through that and he was
pretty shocked by what he found
but he's not a Regulatory Affairs expert
and he doesn't have the kind of you know
hybrid experience I have
so he asked a buddy of mine that runs a
company called trial site news
to uh see whether or not I would take a
look at it
so it comes to me right after it goes to
Bro Byram and I'm asked to do an
independent assessment
uh and and I read through the thing and
I'm pretty shocked
uh and uh and how how shoddy it is it's
just it's atrocious
and um shocking uh to me that this would
be submitted for anything I mean if I
submitted that I would expect to get
reprimanded if not uh basically tarred
and feathered by the FTA
um was that basic was that because of
the efficacy of what you were seeing
what was the most shock it was just
there was no real efficacy data they
weren't even testing the real drug
product they were substituting an mRNA
coating for a firefly protein luciferase
um they so it was the mythology the
methodology of the whole thing basically
no it was it was completely inadequate
by any standards that I had been trained
on completely inadequate as a package
and so I wrote up my assessment and I
was so concerned by what I thought I saw
you know this can't possibly be coming
from Pfizer this can't possibly be you
know I must be missing something so I
sent it to a more senior Regulatory
Affairs guy that I know
that I used to work with in another
contract research organization and he
looked it over and he said oh yeah
Robert everything you said here is true
but you missed a couple of other uh and
and so I said well okay that's great I
need to write this up now as an essay uh
for trial site news do you want your
name on it he's like no no no no no
don't put my name anywhere anywhere near
this thing if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell